[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right we just drove from New York
and we're now in the city they call
Philly the City of Brotherly Love with
my brother Eric right here are going to
be your brother your brother a brother
you are strong yah strong inyart got it
this is actually my hometown
so I'm back in Philly I'm excited my
hair is growing out a little bit I
usually actually wait a really long time
before getting haircuts but now that
BuzzFeed's willing can pay for a bunch
of my haircuts I'm gonna get them like
every couple needs with with interesting
barbers headed outside it sounds good to
me so who's the the barber today so
today I'm gonna be getting a haircut
from the youngest barber in the world I
believe she is eight years old and she
can like talk like I'll be able to talk
as she wasn't at a talk yet can she walk
I mean as long as she can hold like the
barber utensils nothing it doesn't
matter I'm nervous I really I don't want
to mess up my hair
last last haircut video I did my
managers got mad at me because my hair
was too short and they couldn't send me
on auditions so hopefully she gives me a
good haircut and doesn't mess it all up
[Music]
Michael just the youngest barber work in
this bar my world works here
how did that happen so I've created a
program called a junior barber cab one
year ago I thought about teenagers
coming in and learning how to cut here
go on away to college using it as a
treat for themselves or you know to help
off their friends and this little girl
walked in so our mother burger
I'm just a little girl undercover you
know what I was up for the task made it
happen
second class I had the kids cut my hair
and she's thinking about second class
and she was fully prepared for it man
I'll talk about ready to go Cooper's in
hand I'm like you never touch the big
Clippers before she like no I knew I had
something special that's crazy how long
has she been here or like a student or
learning so she's been learning for a
lot of approximately and now she's in my
first class
we're now on class 6 semester 6 she
always helps shows get fair customer
people in the community they get to cut
here in this space before well I'd love
to meet her if you share it here let's
go meet it okay let's do that
[Music]
so how's it going Eric pleasure to meet
you how's everything
this is music this is the 8 year old
young Bart with an apology how ready do
you feel scale the one to ten awesome
true start yeah
[Music]
but what's your favorite drink travel
specialist a croissant I want one I
think we got one absolutely but you have
to get here one okay one two
so why did you get into cutting hair
like what made you want to start
learning how to cut hair well I just
wanted to have a job and at seven right
okay just had a birthday
yes a couple of weeks ago
oh she's doing like proper cleaning
because I'm a bastard just washing hair
fun or is that the least fun part
it's fun of course
how about honey mustard and ketchup and
your mix until hey no that's Caucasian
stuff
[Laughter]
how's my day been yeah my days been
great
what grade are you in third grade or any
of your other third grade friends
cutting hair are you the only one I'm
getting a beard line oh this is amazing
I've never gotten that done before oh
that smells so good sorry for you I was
so relaxing you I'll take this monsoon
you should have a Disney show hang out
like the youngest barber that could
easily be a show this better you're
listening this right here is a Fresh
Prince of bel-air
[Music]
you know this industry can make you ten
thousand dollars per hour
I use a very quiet but mr. Eric is very
[Music]
my only friend anymore okay
and then you'll count me down stop
actually you that's clean looks like a
fade right there nice how's the back
looking this is great thank you so much
this is going to be for the beer
yeah I actually need to get some of that
shea butter business of this thing I
don't think I'm paying this fee that's
what you're gonna buy any stuff oh stop
it
I know we're gonna be best friends
oh my god thank you so much now how do
you want to do this do you want me to
come in your heart or do you want us to
follow you let's go I'll Drive
where's Starbucks all right so we got
the Starbucks drink you're both very
happy you got your drink I got a fresh
new cut thank you so much you did
amazing Cheers
go crazy so you're making the Danny lazy
yeah go crazy handle up how she got so
much stamina got so much RAM enough
gigabyte wish don't dance it up hey let
me do the mast